I have taken my favorite mid term story,
maybe one or two.
Have you heard this before?
The point of this is that you don't
screw around with midterms because people
put their game faces on. You're going
to have your game face this on a Monday.
But maybe 10 years ago,
somebody in the first half of this
class raised their hand as um,
you know, the day before the
lecture, before the midterm
said, oddly enough, what,
uh,
what language will the midterm Ben,
and this is before we had French speaking
sections. So I mean, I don't know,
you ask a question that it was fairly
silly question to give a fairly silly
answers. So I said Croatian I, and
um, so then I started thinking, well,
I'll play a little joke on
him. Ha ha ha. You know,
don't screw around with midterms.
And so I have a colleague who is
Croatian and so I made up the following
question, which he translated in
the Croatian. And so the test,
you come into the tasks and you get
your basic piece of paper with the,
it says the answer,
one of two of the following two questions.
And there's a third question in Croatia
with a translation by evil bonnets.
And the question was mine,
I take full credit or discredit for this.
The question was the population
of Paris in 1831 was 630,000,
uh, 721 people, um,
name these people and in, in, in,
in a second,
in a second column,
a list those who own more
than one apartment. Um,
so if you've got a question said
the population of Paris was 630,000,
731 name these people,
would you answer that question?
Three people did. So you have to
think, what have they been drinking?
What have they been smoking?
And so what do we do?
I'm screwing around with a midterm
and we have three blue books answering
question number three in Croatian
not responding in Croatia.
And that would be extra credit. Uh,
and the first person says, well,
I've been logically enough people.
You must, what people must panic.
I must've done this too when I showed
up late for midterms or whatever,
if I remember to go, uh, you know, you
just, you panic and you start writing.
And the first person that
said, well, you know,
Miriam and he's real interested
in social geography. So roller,
a pretty coherent essay about how the
rich people live in the west and the poor
people live in the east and the wealthier
people in the center and the poor
people in the periphery. So I mean,
so we graded that as a, as a, as a,
as a real answer person.
Number two takes pen.
I remember male or female person number
two takes pen and starts writing a
column.
I'll buy za zoo include,
I'll buy sa John [inaudible],
outbound Isa,
CSEC gay rights, names, rights,
French names sitting there for,
for 45 minutes writing names.
What do you do with that? Uh, I mean,
I called psychiatric surface as
I, I don't know, I get to say,
I got to do with this stuff.
You know, I this crap.
And so the third person a
says question number three,
and then just sort of
just drooled all over the,
all over the blue book for about
the next half hour, you know.
And so we get these things,
get to soggy blue book and you get one
with a kind of a half ass but still okay.
You know, essay on social geography and
you get the third is a bunch of names.
So what do you, how do you grade that?
Uh, we had a council of, you know, a,
a meeting to discuss this
and I remember what we did.
I know we gave the first person some sort
of B plus for the, for the essay and,
and uh, uh, you know, number
two, I think I, I, uh,
can vote the person and then maybe
call the college dean to say, you know,
some of us have Pi San Matias
and much pie on a tee probe.
Namco Ma'am knew. Anyway, I didn't mean
to screw around with it, which in return,
I'm sorry. Oh, I said Bob, maybe I,
I tore it up at the end.
There was probably about 17 or 18 names
and they were in alphabetical order.
So it wasn't that the, the,
the midterm was a total loss,
but that's the last time I
screw around with, with, uh,
with midterms. So, uh, do we,
uh, Brian, uh, mobile, however,
we, uh, uh, do we do our,
we are your people and getting this
in French, the midterm or in English,
but the exam,
and we do the examine in a few minutes.
Are we going to do that in
French horn? Okay. What, uh,
so let, let's, uh, let's
start, where was I got, I got,
I got taken out and taken out there a
little bit here thinking about those old
times. Um, I want to,
I want to do they talk about 1917
and 1918 and talk a little bit, uh,
a little bit, uh, about the,
uh, about the mutinies, um,
of the mutinies have to be seen in the
context of course, in all these assaults.
But above all the battle of the
Somme and the battle of the Somme,
which began on July 1st 19 a 16,
was,
uh, was the darkest moment,
uh, certainly in, um, uh,
in four years of,
of,
of dark days on the first day
of the battle of the Somme.
I always give these
statistics, but there's some
interesting, uh, the first day,
1st of July in 19 a 16,
almost 40 sols and British
soldiers were killed in one day.
I, and, uh, I mean 40,000, sorry,
were wounded and 20,000
were killed on the fray.
First Day there was a casualty for every
half meter of the entire front line.
So one casual d for every
half meter of the front line.
And I gave this,
um,
this is this the first day what I was
going to give you an overview of the
course, but there were more I British
soldiers killed or seriously wounded. Um,
and the first three days
of the battle of the Somme,
then there were Americans
killed in World War One,
a Korea and Vietnam combined.
And then you could include the 4,000 that
had been killed in this, uh, uh, current,
uh, uh, absurd war. Uh,
and so, I mean, that's it.
Those are phenomenal losses.
And so the question again,
when you look at the poisoning of the
political atmosphere and the absence of,
of, uh, of, uh,
able leadership in Europe
in the 1920s in 1930s, uh,
where were they? Uh, in the case of
Britain, they were at that poem went,
hung up on that old barbed wire because
they were dead. And, uh, you know,
sometimes it's, it's easy in, in
British society, such a class society,
and it's easy to kind of poke fun at
Oxbridge Sha folks going in their common
room and then going off to a, you know,
machine gun, a Indian and surgeons, uh,
and this sort of thing, but to
the flower of British, um, uh,
youth perished in the flower of,
of other, uh, countries, youth, uh,
during, uh, during this time.
And so the immune needs have
to be seen in that context.
And I'll come back to them. Uh, uh,
it's back to them, uh, in a, uh,
in a while.
Now I'm 1917 is,
is the crucial a year,
uh,
really in a determining, uh, uh,
the outcome of a war that seemed
like it was going to go on forever,
a forever not, not defined by
truly forever. Uh, but, uh,
that in 19,
end of 1917 and beginning of 1918,
um, into March 19, it will,
after they slow down the
Luton Dorf offensive in 1918,
uh, the military planners
begin to think that the,
when the war in 1920, 19, 21,
maybe if all went spectacularly well
in 1919 and of course there were,
you know, as so many people
died due to win a few, um, uh,
a hundred meters or a kilometer or two
kilometers, three kilometers at best,
there were wags who said, well, if
this rate, we'll reach the Rhine,
somebody figured out by the
year 2007, uh, which is, uh,
where we are now more or less,
if I remember that statistic,
but a two things happen in 1917 that,
that are, um, that are essential.
One is at the Bolshevik
revolution, comes along, uh,
with first the revolution in February
where the people of Saint Petersburg w
wake up and find that the
emperor has no clothes,
that there's police but not troops.
And the bread lines are long. And, uh,
the, uh, the,
the czarist autocracy falls,
uh,
leading to that sort of power vacuum and
Corinne's keys, provisional government.
And of course, at an October, uh,
the Bolsheviks after one attempt that
failed the Bolsheviks seized power.
And at that point, the war changes
dimensions dramatically in the east.
Russia is still in the war until
the treaty of Brest [inaudible], uh,
in March of 1918. Um, but the,
the, the propaganda, which
was more than that of, of, of
war bread and piece, I mean,
that's a motto to live by,
uh, means that, that, uh,
you've got, um, uh,
a de acceleration in the Russian
war effort and you've got massive,
I'm a massive desertions from
the Russian army. Um, now,
one of the amazing things is that the
desertion rate was so low compared to what
you will, you know, what you think would
happen and is rather amazing that the,
that the Russians were, were able
to hold on. Uh, uh, again, I mean,
just as the Germans were close to,
uh, uh, close to, uh, Paris, uh,
particularly in March, 1918, uh, uh,
the German forces are also quite a
close to Petrel God, which, which, uh,
Lennon God had been. Um, I mean,
not letting him go on debt at Saint
Petersburg had been renamed because
Petrograd does sounded a, sounded more
Russian. But the other thing that, that,
that changes the outcome of the
war is that the Americans come in.
Uh, and, um, in the United States, um,
you know, the United States
were supposedly neutral
until 1917. But outside of,
of places with strong German populations,
for example, uh, Philadelphia, uh,
Milwaukee, uh, Chicago, uh,
the majority of Americans supported
the allies as defined by the British,
the French and the Russians, and
particularly through them, uh, uh,
the British component.
Uh,
but it wasn't really that that
brings the Americans into the war,
the German high command to make, again,
one of these interesting long stories,
very, very short had decided that that
the only way they can win is to knock the
British out of the war.
Uh,
and the way that they could knock the
British out of the war is to stop the
supply of, of a munitions
of food, of grain,
of almost anything else you can
imagine to, um, to Great Britain. Now,
how you're going to do that? Well, the
way you're going to do that is with, um,
a campaign of, of unrestricted
submarine warfare, the famous u boats,
uh, that, uh, the sink, an
incredible, uh, a number of ships.
Um, and, um, the German, uh,
the German government goes down,
sends representatives downs to the,
down to the docks in New York and
other ports, Boston and other places.
And they put up warning saying
that, that, uh, you know,
the civilian passengers or any other
Americans who go on ships ought to know
that they're entering a war zone
and could be sunk. Um, and the,
the German u boat sink, some
ships with American, it's on them.
Uh, the most dramatic event was at
the sinking of the Lusitania, uh,
which I'm sure you all know
about in which lots of Americans,
I can't remember how many,
but it might was hundreds and hundreds.
It might've even been a thousand.
Uh,
I apologize for not having a
statistic in my eye and my head, uh,
were killed off a, I think
it's fairly near, um, Ireland.
And of course the Americans
go wild and say that, uh,
uh, this, this, um, you know,
ship was carrying,
passengers are going over to Britain and,
and uh, civilians. And, uh, this was,
uh, an act of piracy and active war,
an act of murder, et Cetera,
et cetera. It turns out that,
and I think it was a 1960s, they're
1970s. I vaguely remember this.
They sent divers down to down into the
Lusitania and they found that as the
Germans had claimed, was absolutely
correct, that the Americans were, uh,
the ship was carrying munitions.
And therefore, I mean,
I'm not defending the sinking of the
ship. I'm not defending, you know,
of the thinking of any ship.
Uh, but, uh, but clearly it was,
it was carrying weapons.
And that's one of the reasons that the
ship went down was such a dramatic impact
is because all the munitions blow up
when the, when the German torpedo hit it.
But, but the law and the over
the long run, what happens is,
is that that the man who was going
to keep America out of war, I would,
Roy Wilson pro, former president
of Princeton University, uh,
ends up taking the US into war.
And those of you who had American
history from Glenda or, or, uh,
other people want to go more, other folks,
um, here will know that, that, you know,
in the end, I mean, most Americans really
didn't want to go to war. And, uh, Wilson,
who was the first American president,
by the way,
ever to leave the United States
during a term of a term of office,
a ghost of Versailles, uh, to the
treaty of Versailles after the war.
And then he can't get the treaty
ever, uh, uh, ratified by, uh,
by the u s congress. After that. I
mean, his, his repudiation is, is,
um, a really complete, uh, unfortunately
for him at the end of the war. Now,
what difference did the
Americans come into?
The warm of coming into the warm mean
in 1917. It was not the, the troops.
I mean, lots of troops.
I begin to arrive, um,
and led by pure perishing,
John Perishing, who had done,
who had honed his skills by, uh, you
know, shooting down Mexicans, uh, in, uh,
in Mexico. Uh, it, uh,
and they have the reputation for
being sort of cowboys and earnest.
And they are the, uh, the typical
American image is really a,
though it's been desmin devastated in
the last four or five years, but, uh, uh,
really is created by the
Americans arriving to fight.
And you're well trained pistol, uh, uh,
wielding a sharp shooters and all that.
And they first go to the
first fight at Chateau Gfe,
which is not very far from Paris.
It's northeast of Paris in 1917.
But that's not what makes the difference.
Uh,
American troops in the long run
will help tilt the scale to, uh,
to the allies, uh, and it
compensates for, um, for,
for what we've discussed in terms of
the French not having a, you know,
they're gonna run out of soldiers.
But the big difference is
that the curves cross, uh,
that the curves of the ability of the
Germans to supply, uh, their own forces,
uh, that the German war machine, uh,
is not going to be able to compete
with the combined power of American
industrial might.
And Detroit can be easily converted.
The factories in Detroit
and Ypsilanti and Flint,
Michigan in lots of other places can be
easily transformed into production of,
uh, uh, if slanty yeah. Into a
production of arms and, and places like,
like that. And so the curves cross, and
it's at that point when many people in,
uh, you know, the French and the British
high command along with the Americans,
they know they're going to win the war,
uh, in a, in a, in the long run. Uh,
but the question at what, at what
cost? And, and, and, you know,
the lively discussion as there had been
in Germany, over German war aims, uh,
you know, the Germans, if
they win the war and the West,
they're going to want
demand part of Belgium,
they're going to want to probably more
of Lohan, uh, et Cetera, et cetera.
Uh, uh, the French also, uh,
have their war aims that are going to
want to have a permanent French, you know,
presence. They're talking about
that and in the Rhineland and,
and as well as taking Alsace and
Lauryn bet. And so that helps set up,
which I'll come back to talk about
in a while, uh, 19, 18 march,
because that's when the German say,
baby, it's now or never. And so that's,
that's the, the big Luton Dorf
offensive, which I'll come back to in,
in March of 1918. That's
important, uh, uh, uh, to say,
to discuss at least, uh, a little bit.
Now what about the mutinies and
what about other aspects of,
uh, you know, of, of the war? Um,
uh, they have to do with, with,
with, with the home front and in
the mutinies are not on the, on the,
on the home front, but they're,
they're quite a close to it.
As I said at the beginning,
um,
as I said at the beginning, your, um,
most people in France did not want
war in 1914 but because it was easy to
portray Germany as the aggressors,
which they were,
the vast majority of the population,
uh,
obviously was prepared to hold
on because of the proximity, uh,
certainly of, of Paris,
uh, to, uh, to the front.
And this is right through the war.
It's right through into the failure
of the Luton Dorf offensive.
Now to be sure there are tensions
within French society about the war.
There was tremendous, uh, resentment and
you can see photos of this resentment, uh,
as, as, uh, in, in Paris.
Opera was one place where
they distributed coal.
That was ray rationed in
order to have to have heat.
And as you know from the discussion
previously of the Golden Buddha, you know,
that's where many of the
famous restaurants and cafes,
the cafe now, he can't, uh,
uh, the, the, the cafe lawpay
and ironically, the cafe de
la pay, the cafe of peace,
uh, and all those things are, are,
are, um, uh, located. And so as, um,
as people waited in line to hope to get
a few chunks of coal in order to stay
warm and in these cold a
Parisian a winters, uh,
they saw the fancy people in their big
cars. I've driven by chauffeurs, uh,
going off to the great restaurants and
people who had profit tiered from the war
and named me a war in
which people, uh, uh,
do not profit enormously in,
in which some aspects of big business
are not just gleeful with every extended
tour of duty. And, and,
uh, you'll have that,
you'll have discovered something
that I didn't know existed.
And so there's a lot of tension toward,
toward up, uh, a to a profiteers,
to legal, the big guys, the fact guys,
they global ne the big hats. Um,
and you've got those tensions,
but you have more than that. You have
tensions between those people who, uh,
PA peasants, they Payza
who are, um, you know,
conscripted without any real possibility,
unless they've already had
two brothers killed. Uh,
and that saves them. And for example,
skilled workers in the armament industry,
uh, for example, around
Santa Tn, Santa Tn, uh,
is an armament manufacturing town or
was they used to make bikes there too?
Neither. They don't make it either
there anymore or in tune in, in,
in the Co has a places
that make arms people,
skilled workers got out of
the draft because of that.
And thus they worked very hard.
Uh, uh, but there was, you know,
there are some tension, uh, towards,
towards that from, uh, from, uh,
for example, people in, in the Macias
on tile, uh, where you have the, the,
the most endless lists of names killed
that one could ever see in Avania and
places like that. So you have
those sorts of tensions as well.
Now, the role of women in all
of this is of course crucial.
A because it's in the factories.
Uh,
particularly and not ski and not highly
skilled work because they didn't have
the from us. You are the training
in that, that women step up and uh,
and replace men. And also, again,
the role of nurses is so important.
And so that's what I was inconceivable
for many French women after all of this,
not to get the vote after World War One,
whereas in Britain, uh, women, uh, uh,
get the vote after World War Two and
the United States, Rosie the riveter,
you know, working in a factory
in Detroit or in, in, uh,
uh, Pittsburgh, uh, you know,
became sort of an icon for a, you
know, sort of in the Crypto, uh,
uh, feminist movement,
uh, in later decades. Uh,
so you have some tensions there.
I mean,
you also had workers who would come
back and of course, after the war,
if they were lucky enough to
survive Brunello top Bruno Gabon,
we'll probably talk about this next
week after midterm, you know, they,
they get thrown out there the last hired,
so they're the first fired.
And there's some tensions between males
and females over that too, because, well,
the males had been out in the trenches
and then they want those jobs back and,
and all of that.
But another thing is rather interesting
is of course the role of women in, in,
in them, the nurses and the
big, you know, the, the,
the northern French nuns and the Belgium
nuns with those huge hats. Uh, you know,
the, the, the, and,
and it was easy to become anticlerical
and we've talked about that before. But,
but one of the things that calm
that situation is the role of,
of the clergy in particular of the female
clergy in attending to these horrible,
horrible wounds and, and some cases
going, you know, going to the front is,
you know, working with
ambulance as in this sort of
thing. It's a other women did,
who didn't happen to be nuns. And
if, for example, the, the, the, the,
the case of Leon has been documented
and Leon was the capital of the Radical
Party with the big are
socially conservative and v
but very, and, but, but, uh,
moderate politically, but based
upon built upon anti clericalism,
uh,
and in Leon where there was a vibrant
kind of anti clericalism before World War
one that calms down because, you know,
these nuns who people, uh, you know,
attacked, representing in
some ways institutionalized
role of the, of, of, of, uh,
the Catholic Church and French society.
We're extraordinarily heroic and so
are these priests and, uh, you know,
in ministers and, and, and, and
indeed, rabbis who of course,
who get killed by shells, uh, as they're
giving the last rights to all of these,
uh, people who, who have been killed.
And there's another attention
to that's not talked about
so much. Uh, but I, I can,
I've heard it in the end. There's a
collective memory of a, you know what,
where we live too. Is that one of the
things that happens with the warrant,
obviously when you look
at a map of France, uh,
that they popped him all like the aisle
then and the n and the mountain and,
and the product Kallai and the na are
basically German or the front line is
running right through that.
Did they pop them all?
So you've got these millions of people
who become refugees and they are going,
Eh,
you know,
they're in a more organized fashion
than in 1940 when everybody's seen the
pictures of them walking along the roads,
caring what they can,
and then diving into the ditches
as the, as the, uh, loose, uh,
as the Luftwaffe, the
German, a fighter plane,
the German air force is strafing
them in a more organized fashion,
but you still have to somewhere to go.
You have to have someplace to end
up where you're going to be fed.
And so where they end up,
well,
they ended up in the places
in France where there are not,
where there's not fighting.
And uh, and it became,
is that people get tired of the war
by 1917. Well, at the time, I mean,
everybody's tired of the war, but, but as,
as as one gets even tired or of the war,
you hear the sort of grumbling about
these people from the north and they speak
at different accent. Uh, in some
cases if they, if they speak German,
they speak a different language.
If they speak slimish.
And there are lots of Flemish
speakers who come down from, from, uh,
the Knauf and places like
cause Buka and all of that. Um,
and so they are strains
on local resources,
which are already extremely limited.
And so you even have this talk,
a grumbling,
it's not more than that,
but grumbling in cafes and bars about,
uh,
Paris is war,
but also about the Bush do know
that is the Germans of the north.
And in one of the things is that a lot
of people in the north of France or
blonde and a lot of people in the majority
of people in the south of France have
dark hair.
And so all of a sudden there's is a ride.
It was a silly way of viewing it,
but this is how people viewed it is that,
you know,
you had your bom blind people in the
south and you have dark people in north.
I mean that life is like that. But you
have the, the rival of these people,
many of whom will collect their Dutch,
you know,
who are arriving and who caused some
sort of strain, a strain on, uh,
the building of communities to, uh, to
take care of those who perceived as,
as of their own.
And so 1917 is a big year
for that as well. You have,
you have other kinds of, uh, uh, you have,
you have other kinds of problems you
have in 1917 is the year lots of men and
women go on strike. Now, they are not,
these are not defeatist in quotes strikes,
but the strikes and Santa tn and many
of them are, are involving women, uh,
are demands for better working
conditions for better wages.
They're part of the Sacred Union Union
Hay, but they want better conditions.
And so the strikes in 1917, again,
they're not the fetus strikes,
they want to win the war, but it's the
same thing as the, the movement, uh,
before the war for better conditions,
uh,
that why should you work for worse
conditions than men, for example?
Or why should it work for conditions when
the prophet hears are getting rich and
the global born the big bonus, the
big hats are getting wealthy. Why,
why should you have terrible conditions?
And so these strikes, you know,
are very widespread. Clem soul.
Uh, it'll come, it has more power.
In 1917, he becomes prime
minister. He says, I wage war.
I wage war. I wait. Wage war.
That's all. Uh, there were
attempts to break the strikes,
but it's a year where the, the, the
morale of the Home Front, uh, is,
is extremely, um, it's
fragile. It's more fragile,
1917 than any other time.
And there seems to be this enormous
disparity between this or a howling
propaganda of, of, of big,
big newspapers in which everything is a
great victory and defeats are just tiny
setbacks a step back. And if, if
things are so damn good, why, you know,
why are the Germans still close to Paris?
And so it becomes pretty
hard to explain now.
They don't have the problems that
the Germans will have because,
and that's a different situation. A very
good book edited by my friend, um, uh,
j winter, uh, and, uh, coming from
the zone, do we do a rollback,
uh,
called Capitol cities and at war,
because conditions are worse in
Berlin than they are in, in Paris. Uh,
but conditions are much better
in London than they are in Paris.
And that's the only for
fairly obvious reasons.
So the losses are still a equally bad,
uh,
so that that year in 1917
is, uh, uh, is a bad year.
Uh, but overall, uh, things
come are calmed down. And, um,
uh, for these reasons I've already
said it is a, a, a turning point.
Now, what about these, the, the strikes,
I mean, what about the mutinies?
Uh, how serious were the mutinies?
They were probably only two, uh,
divisions that were totally reliable
standing between the Germans and Paris at
that point. Not reliable. Uh,
again, to the extent that, that the,
that they want the Germans to win because
they don't, but they want, for example,
the rights of the French
were trying to keep, uh,
representatives from the Socialist Party,
from going to Switzerland or going to
to Sweden to meet an international peace
conferences, uh, and that sort
of thing. Um, but one of the,
I spoke earlier earlier,
whenever it was Monday,
about this sort of discontinuity
or the contrast between, uh,
the soldiers view of the war and that
other civilians and one of the, uh,
and how the soldiers back on leave didn't
want to talk about it. And, and, uh,
you know, couldn't really give that
precise kinds of information anyway, uh,
because off it's all swirling around
them and they don't really know what's
going on in other places
except where they are. Uh,
but one of the best evidences
of that is the fact that nobody,
as far as as we can
tell at the home front,
really knew at the time of the,
uh,
of the mutinies about how serious
and widespread the mutinies were,
uh, that they didn't really know.
Now remember also that, that in fact,
this is one of the key sources for Bruno
coupons. Magnificent book, uh, on, um,
uh, Vic called rated the French
translation to English would be,
we'd be sort of something like a
victory plunged into morning. Ah,
that is the return of the soldiers.
One of the principle sources are letters
written by soldiers from the front that
were collected and censored by,
uh,
by military sensors who don't want the,
these letters revealing to civilians
much of what's going on at all.
And so that also explains why people
at the home front really didn't know a
about how widespread these new knees were,
nor did the Germans,
nor did the British, uh,
uh,
outside of the high command have
any sense of what was going on.
Now, um, these mutinies,
it's not, uh, uh, to, uh,
hard to say, uh, why, you know,
these movies take place in, in,
in, in, uh, when they do, uh, or,
or why they take place at all.
Uh, it is not, again, to feed us and
they don't want the Germans to win. Uh,
they have some respect,
lots of respect for the German soldiers
that were fighting against the law at
the end of the war. They still just with
seeps out of these letters is maybe on,
we'll talk about this next time, uh, is,
uh, uh, you know, hatred for, you know,
the horrible hunt, et Cetera, et
cetera. But is that, you know,
anybody could tell that these tactics
were just killing hundreds of thousands of
people for nothing,
for nothing.
That there wasn't going to be a French
British breakthrough that the battle of
the Somme grounds to, uh, a
halt all along the front, uh,
for obvious reasons after, uh, you know,
a, you know, after a matter of, of,
of, of really days but weeks,
uh, and that there isn't any, uh,
any, any hope, um, that it began
when one company, oh, by the way,
how do we know this? Uh, you know, we
don't know it from Kirk Douglas. Um,
most archives in France are,
um,
can be opened up 50 years
after the fact. So, uh,
what is your,
is this 2000 something where the 2007 so
we could see the archives 50 years ago,
but not, uh, uh, 49 years ago,
but with the military archives,
because this was so sensitive,
the mutinies,
all of these documents were in
the war archives and vast sen,
and I saw them before they were
open because I bribed my way in. Uh,
I was not to see them,
I was working on something else,
but they're the person that ran this, that
we're arc. I was just totally clueless.
Totally clueless. And she
lived for about, you know,
three hour Tris or lunch breaks I guess
more appropriately. And then, uh, um,
and I knew these documents were there
and so I knew also somebody tipped me off
that the Gao,
the end likes a stamps.
And so I would put all these wild
sort of stamps on my, you know,
mail letters when people still
use stamps and, and, and, and,
and I had one from Latin America and one
from Africa. And, and this guy comes up,
he's okay. Very beautiful. The stamps.
I said, Oh, do you like stamps?
And you're, yeah. So, yeah. So,
well would you like these? Oh,
thank you so much. And they're pretty
soon I'm in the, in the archives, uh,
in the back, you know, and,
and he's, he's an officer too.
He's some sort of a lieutenant,
a guy, either ogre guy. Anyway,
so I bribed my way in and you could
see these, all of these, these cartons,
and they were changed.
They were literally all chained in this
big kind of capsule look like a space
capsule,
except it was just looks like the basement
of Branford college or something. But,
but you, you couldn't, you couldn't,
you couldn't get into those pigs that was
taught to be the national disgrace, uh,
that there had been these,
uh, uh, these mutinies, uh,
and the mutinies were, uh,
were indeed why widespread?
And so what happens is
that a refusals to go, uh,
to go over the top a simply spread.
They spread like wildfire.
Soldiers say they don't want to get
killed anymore for 5 cents a day.
In some places there are red flags go up.
In some places they're black flags,
which are the, the, the
flags of anarchism. But,
uh, remember that, that uh,
you know, the Socialists had also
joined the, the uh, uh, joined,
uh, the sacred union. And as you'll get
ends up being minister of Transport,
minister of a communication
or something like that in 19,
um, uh, uh, in, but in 1915,
if I remember correctly,
and two regiments that are posted and
Swat Soul Swipe Sloan is not very far away
from Paris. That's swa song was about a
45 minute drive away from Paris by car.
Now two regiments decide they're going
to march on Paris to try to set things
right.
They're going to force the Chamber of
deputies to find a way to end the war.
Not to, to say we want the Germans
to win, uh, but to find a way,
get some sort of negotiated so
that this carnage, uh, stopped. Um,
most of the generals who
were fairly clueless, uh,
see organized Bolshevik propaganda
behind this or pacifist,
those people coming out of Sweden
or Switzerland and trying to stop a,
a the, the useless way this
war is being fought. Um,
uh, it may and June about
about 40,000 soldiers were,
um, involved in collective,
um, uh, acts of, of uh,
of refusal. Uh, and, um, the,
although the generals insisted in their
correspondence that those 40,000 people
were cowards. I know this,
obviously it was not the case,
and many of them had already been
shot up and already been wounded.
And already we're, we're, we're,
we're, we're going back. Um, and, um,
the first signs of this, by
the way, are the soldiers were,
were supposed to move up in order
to prepare to go over the top,
began buying like sheep, going Baa, Baa,
the way that sheet by and the way to the
slaughter, the, the slaughter house. Uh,
because that's, that's where
they were going. Um, now there,
there was socialist and passive as
pacifists literature that had, uh, uh,
happily enough, uh, you know, in my view
had to, had gotten into the trenches. But,
but, but th th this is not the motivation,
uh, and pay town, uh, you know,
who ends up being one of the evil forces
in France, but this was the early town,
uh, when pay town, uh, he realizes
that, that this is not the case. Uh,
that, uh, um,
and in fact the repression is much less
severe than many of the generals wanted
a more about that, uh,
uh, in, in a minute. Um,
and so he ends the policy.
Petain does have these
mad attacks over the top,
the whistles blow,
and then they simply get slaughtered.
Uh, they, uh, in some areas,
and we don't have exact statistics because
there were certainly some people are
just put up against the wall
and shot in and we don't know.
It's just like after
1945, uh, we don't know.
We have a guest of 10,000 people
were killed in the reprisals in 1845.
But that's, that's a pretty
rough account. Uh, but, um,
there were 3,400, 27 condemnations, um,
about 10% of the people who
were, who faced some kind of, of,
of court martial for something they
did or something they didn't do. Um,
and 49 were condemned to death,
which is not, I'm not from,
for condemning anybody, uh,
uh, to death. Um, but, um,
it, it, um, and, and these were
carried out as in the movie, uh,
as in the film, uh, immediately, you
know, it's just up against the wall, Bang,
Bang. And Peta, uh, tries
to, he tries to bring in,
um, uh, he tries to bring
in better conditions,
I mean ups the booze ration as well.
And of course that was a pretty happy,
uh,
so I'm in all, in fact, I said 40,000,
but there's another statistic, uh,
that, that, that, that goes as
high as 70,000 people. Uh, and uh,
let me throw in a statistic. As long as
we're doing that, uh, for strikes and set,
1917,
there were 689 strikes,
a affecting 300,000 workers.
That's a lot,
twice all meal,
300,000 workers.
And that's compared to
98 strikes in 19 a 16.
But again, uh, we know
fascinating, um, uh, aspect.
I'm repeating,
uh,
I is that this was not known and
this was not known. Uh, you know,
then you couldn't drive it in 45
minutes, but this was not known, uh, in,
in Paris by the general
population. Uh, what had,
what had happened. And then
the end, uh, France, uh,
France, France holds on now
in the spring of 19. Um,
and the spring of 1918,
the Germans launched their victory drive,
uh, in quotes, uh,
the first major German offensive
since 1914 before spend.
The British and the French attempting
to break through. Now, if the same time,
the Austrian Hungarian Empire,
uh,
the army is all the cracks that were
quite predicted and predictable. Uh,
there are all sorts of
problems there and funds.
Yosef has died in 1916 and so the Germans
are quite unsure whether the fostering
going to empire is going to be
able to hold on, uh, uh, in, uh,
uh, you know, fighting against
the Italians for example,
and member of the breast,
the Tosca is not, uh, is
not signed until March of,
of 1918.
And the Americans have by spring of 1918,
325,000 soldiers. That's not a
huge number of soldiers, but,
but there's still three times,
Michigan football stadium
full. So that's, you know,
that's,
that's a lot of people.
So Luda nerf decides on a massive
German assault along the poor,
old some river,
therefore avoiding the mud
of Flanders and avoiding, uh,
the forts of eastern
France around Vietnam.
He was encouraged by the fact that
there are younger soldiers that are just
barely 18 that had been put
into, uh, uh, into, uh, uh,
the ranks. Uh, and he also has
brought up old, much older men too.
So they have some serious troops in order
to try to pull off this breakthrough.
And so on 21st of March,
1918 after a relatively brief bombardment
of five hours as opposed to five days,
1.6 million men who could
have imagined these numbers,
who could have imagined these numbers.
In 1913,
a 1.6 million men attacked
the ally defenses, uh,
in five separate,
uh,
our defenses in five separate
offenses over a front of a 40 miles.
And they do break through in five days.
Some German units have pushed
forward more than 40 miles.
Uh, the, uh, uh, uh,
complimentary attack in Flanders,
uh, does very well indeed. Uh, and the,
the British troops and the French has
as a, you know, a General Haig. Uh, uh,
in Britain famously once said,
we're fighting with
their backs to the wall.
And on Easter Sunday of that year,
again,
the shells from big Bertha loved all
those miles from the north fall on Paris
through to Rivoli.
You can still see a sign where it
took out an apartment building,
Church of Santa Fe, uh, uh,
you know, right near the sand,
the same thing. We'll have
our [inaudible], uh, up by
Moh Parnassus, same thing.
So these shells a fall, and
they begin, uh, taking, uh,
alive. But what happens, uh,
was predictable and predicted is that
as on the small scale in the big scale,
the Germans begin to outrun
their cover and supplies,
and they begin at each one of these five
points of German offensive to encounter
a stiff a resistance.
On July 15th,
Ludendorff tries a last desperate
attack, uh, and it's, um,
it's, it's repulsed. And for Luna Andorf.
He knew this was the last
chance to win the war.
And at that point he knows it's a lafond,
the article, the end of the green beans,
uh, that they're simply not going
to win. And that the French,
their resources swollen by the
mirror can entrance into the war, uh,
are not going to sue for an armistice,
armistice until they've pushed
the Germans back across, uh,
the Rhine.
And we're at that point,
morale plunges dangerously in Germany.
In January of 1918 250,000 German workers
defy the government by going on strike
and strikes were illegal during the war.
There's all sorts of hoarding and so
there's a big problem and the French, uh,
forces counter or the allies,
the British,
the French and the Americans
CounterTack in July.
And at this point when they're in the
open for the first time tanks that you've
all seen, pictures of them
stuck in the mud, uh, now,
but when they're in the open
tanks began to work rather well,
and they'd been getting to adopt
a strategy of having soldiers,
infantry following tanks, and therefore
not getting picked off, uh, a, you know,
in such huge numbers,
and they begin to make a big a difference.
Uh,
on the 8th of August,
1918 of the German army's
darkest day, the, uh,
there are all sorts of attacks against
the German lines and a British force
moves force moves eight miles.
Uh,
and that though that's a territory
that was unimaginable, uh,
in the beginning, at this point,
Luton to RF us the hapless of Wilhelm,
the second that is all over,
but the shouting and you better
figure out some way of bringing, uh,
this whole thing to, uh,
to an end. And as, as,
as you know, in the end, uh, uh, go home,
the second will slither
across the Dutch border. Uh,
and the armistice will be signed
in a railroad car and comb PN, uh,
uh, north of Paris. Um,
there's still a railroad car
there or it's not the same one.
And that's where Hitler insisted on the
declaration of the armistice in 1940
being signed. So the war ends
on the 11th of, of, of November,
1918. And as you know, there
were many people, not many,
but there are lots of people killed after
were because they didn't know that the
pharmacist had come along and that the,
that the biggest pan-am
DEMEC ever in human history,
at least since the black death,
uh, in the 14th century, uh,
the Spanish flu, uh, is, it was called
a, it probably started in India, uh,
but had already began to
slip a sweep through, uh, a
sweep through the world. So,
uh,
things were not getting better and better,
but they were getting worse and worse.
Uh, just a few, I mean, obvious,
uh, statistics. I mean, you can see
these all over, but, um, uh, it,
it is, uh, it, it, it, it is staggering.
Beforehand was something that Jay Winter,
uh, has, um, has, uh,
begun one of his books, uh,
with, um, and just in terms
of dead and wounded, uh,
just a couple,
don't reckon,
write these down and you write it down
or don't write them down. But anyway, uh,
Russia dead,
1 million,
800,000 wounded 5 million.
Now that ain't nothing like World War II,
25 million dead in the Soviet
Union in World War Two.
But 1.8 million is a
rather lot, uh, to, uh,
to be killed in France. Uh,
the French, um, at least two,
probably more than this, but, uh, you,
you hear figures from one point, uh,
1.4 million to 1.5 million.
Dead and wounded,
4 million, 266,000, Great Britain,
including the empire, the
dominion, the Australians, uh,
the Kenyans a dead 908,000
and wounded 2 million.
The Italians, 58,000, 578,000, excuse me,
with about a million wounded, uh, in
Serbia, which is a very small country.
Dead, 278,000 wounded, 133,000,
tiny Belgium killed 38,000 wounded 44,
uh,
uh, and among the central
powers, Germany, 2 million dead,
2 million dead. After all that,
you know, with your armies,
how do you explain to the folks back home,
all those people dead,
why you've surrendered will,
must be someone's fault.
And that's what the right would argue.
It's the Jews. It was a socialist.
So it was the communist there
hadn't a stab in the back.
How do we explain this
to the folks back home?
A wounded 4 million more
than that. Austria, Hungary.
The amazing thing is they held on
so long giving you all the national,
given all the national differences,
1.1 million with wounded, uh,
3.6 million.
I mean,
these are just statistics that
are so incredible. In France,
there are 36,000 communes and there
were only 12 that didn't have somebody
killed. And that's where when you go
to any French commun except those 12,
you will see, uh, uh, you know,
a list of those people killed
or even inside churches.
Sometimes they'll have the parish ones
and if the war monuments or near the
churches, that tends to happen more in
areas that were still Christianized,
where people still went to church.
And I mentioned this once before,
but if you go to the booboo
nay or the Rda, you still,
you find these war memorials that are
sort of like Voltaire of God exists.
How could he or she let this
happen with broken crosses,
shattered crosses that were lamenting
that this could happen in a,
in a so called civilized world.
And of course,
one thing that happens after the
war, it as, as Charles pointed out,
you know the other day is that if
you've been told, if you ate, if you,
you're an African in their urination and
you've been told that this is the great
civilization, that the Europeans,
they've got it all, you know,
you've been told by them that
they're better than you. How do you,
how do you reconcile that to what they're
screaming at you and they're little
schools trying to teach you
their language? If they're,
if they're so damn better,
how could they bring, uh, all
of this upon, uh, upon Europe?
There is by the way,
but one soldier left in Great
Britain who still alive for more.
We're one,
he's a fellow called Harry Payne.
He was born in 1898 and somebody
just published a book about him.
And periodically on Armistice Day, he
is interviewed. You can hear him on BBC,
but with the passing of time, of
course, uh, you don't have that anymore.
And I can remember even my
Magennis, I can remember, you know,
seeing these very aged people
coming out in November 11th, uh,
so proud of, you know, of what they
did, uh, fighting and you know,
in the Americans too that did.
But in those days,
those were different wars and
those were different countries.
And I would argue also that was
a very different America. Anyway,
just to simply end with something
that Jay winter leaves us, uh, with.
He has a wonderful book, uh, uh,
about morning in memory
and he begins with a film.
He begins with a film by about Goss.
I bet a Goss ga.
And Ce did a very long overrated film
on Napoleon Napoleon with a famous
snowball fight. But he did a book.
He did, uh, uh, he takes a Zoloft,
his title, but he did a movie called Jack
Hughes. He makes it a 19, 18 and 19, 19.
He made it before, uh, the
war. Uh, his is over. Uh,
the hero is a guy called John
Diaz. He's a wounded soldier, poet.
And he goes crazy.
He begins to lose his mind.
So many people that did after
all that in World War One,
he escapes from a mental hospital and he
goes back to his village and he brings
all the villagers together and he tells
him about a dream that he's had a in the
asylum. And um, in the dream in the movie,
you see a battlefield
graveyard with all the crosses.
They're all there and
they're all a skewed.
And a big black cloud comes up behind
the village graveyard in the ground,
in the, in the, in the
movie. And magically,
these ghostlike figures emerged from
the grays with tattered bandages,
missing arms,
their bandages to began.
I began to unravel around their head.
And some are blind who they've lost their
sight and some are coughing out their
lungs from the poison gas and they leave
the battlefield and they go back to
their own villages to see if the
sacrifices have been worth it.
And what they find is what Jay calls
the pettiness, a civilian life.
That the black marketing,
uh, the profiteering,
their wives had been sleeping around.
Uh, things aren't the way they should be.
Whereas they have suffered, but
they come back, they're alive again,
but they're really dead.
And their appearance so terrifies the
villagers that they decide the men their
ways and to, and to, to be
big, become better people,
better people. And so the, these,
these ghostlike figures
in their advantages,
they marched back to the cemetery and
they go back into their graves and it's
all over. But what's it's, it's,
but what's really interesting about it
is it some of the soldiers who were on
leave at that time on premise,
y'all were used as extras in the
movie and you can identify them.
Someone who has lost his arm. Really, it's
not a fake missing arm. It's a real one.
And some of them who were there in the
movie go back to the war and are killed.
They die real deaths in their
graves with their tattered vantages.
And as if art and reality has emerged.
And that's an important theme in
all of this because there's no war,
no more powerful moment in history that
has brought us such great literature and
all of this,
and there's no war like this ever.
That end leaves so many
demons into the world,
and as is some of those demons that
we will now next turn, but not today.
Good luck than the midterm. Have
a great weekend. Rock and roll.